للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب حصه
من اخبارنا في تفاعلكم اليوم حيث فاجا
العالم امس في منشور على منصته تروس سوشل
قال فيه انه سيتم اعتقاله يوم الثلاثاء من
قبل محكمه منهاتن ودعا انصاره للاحتجاج
والتظاهر وقال لهم استعيدوا بلادنا القضيه
التي يتحدث عنها
وبين نجمه الافلام الاباحيه
واسمها الحقيقي ستيفاني
في القضيه بدفع 130 الف دولار قبل اسابيع
من الانتخابات 2016 لشراء صمتها بشان
علاقه جمعتهما قبل سنوات وهي العلاقه التي
كانت ستضر بحظوظ المرشح الرئه حينها في
الفوز في الانتخابات رغم ان دفع المبلغ
يعتبر بحد ذاته قانونيا لكن مكتب المدعي
العام في نيويورك الذي ينظر في القضيه
يتعامل مع الدفع على انه تبرح خفي لحمله
الرئيس وهذا انتهاك لقانون التمويل
الانتخابي وكتبت ترامب في منشوره عن فساد
التحقيق بهذه القضيه التي وصفها بالخرافيه
والمكشوفه بالكامل وقال ان المحكمه تم
تمويلها بشكل كبير من قبل جورج سورس رجل
الاعمال الامريكي المعروف بعدائيته واذا
كانت مزاعم ترامب بشان توقيف وشيك صحيحه
فستكون هذه السابقه وهي اول مره من نوعها
لرئيس سابق يواجه اتهامات جنائيه كانت
ترامب نشر البوست بعد ساعات من تداول
انباء بان المدعي العام لمقاطعه منهات
يخطط لتوجيه لائحه اتهامات ضده الاسبوع
المقبل منشور ترامب اثر جدلا ونقاشا واسعا
اضطرت بعدها محاميته للتوضيح في بيان قالت
فيه ان الرئيس السابق لم يكتب منشوره مع
علم مباشر بتوقيت اي اعتقال وقال محاميته
لترامب ان منشوره استند الى تقارير
اخباريه متهمه مكتب المدعي العام في
منهاتم باجراء محاكمه سياسيه
كثيرون اقلقهم منشور ترامب واعلانه
وتذكروا تغريدته التي دعا فيها انصاره
للاحتجار وقال ان الانتخابات سرقت منه
واعتبرت التغريده تحريض على الاحتجاجات
التي انتهت التي انتهت باحداث الشغب في
الكابيتول كما نتذكر وكم علق كثيرون على
الانباء متسائلين ان كان فعلا سيعتقل ومات
داعي ذلك ومن المعلقين كان الملياردير
الالماس الذي كتب على تويتر ان انه اذا تم
توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب رسميا فستتم
اعاده انتخاب ترامب بانتصار ساحق في عام
2024 وكمان اسم المرشح للرئاسه في عام
2024 تروم يتصدر الاخبار ايضا بسبب تطورات
اخرى فشركه يوتيوب اعلنت اعاده تفعيل
حسابه من بعد مرور عامين على حظره وعبر
تغريده على تويتر اعلنت يوتيوب انه لم تعد
قناه دونا مقيده ويمكنها تحميل محتوى جديد
وانه تم تقييم المخاطر وان القرار هو من
باب اعطاء فرص متكافئه لكل المرشحين
الفتره المقبله وفي تغريده ثانيه قالت
يوتيوب ان قناه ترامب ستبقى خاضعه
لسياساتها مثل اي قناه اخرى وللتذكير فقد
كان تم اعاده حسابات ترامب على تويتر
وفيسبوك وانستجرام من اشهر وامس فورا
استخدم يوتيوب حيث يملك اكثر من مليونين
مشترك وحمل اول فيديو كما نشاره نفسه على
فيسبوك ايضا الذي يتابعه عليه 34 مليون
شخص ورساله ترامب في المنصات في المنصتين
كانت لقد عدت
شعري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]